Hi everyone. I'm Sachin Gupta and I'm a
software engineer. The title is exactly
what it sounds like. Your coding agent
is creating review debt. Before I start,
sit with the title for a second. Notice
what it is not saying. I'm not saying
that coding agents are bad.
I'm not saying they don't make us
faster. I'm saying they they're creating
a kind of debt that nobody is measuring.
And that debt is going to come to you.
Over the next few minutes, here's what
I'm going to do. I will define what
review debt is. I'll walk five signal
families that are going to compose it.
I'll score three real pull requests side
by side and I will show you a cross repo
scan of over 500 PRs, which is nothing
but three public code bases. So let's
go.
Look here.
Here's the gap nobody's measuring.
GitHub's 2025 October's report that
covers
almost every public pull request on the
planet shows that the commits climbed
25% year over year. And now over the
same year, comments on the comments
dropped 27%. Now, these comments are
nothing but the proxy for review
activity.
Code production volume actually went up,
but the review attention went down. They
moved in opposite directions that to in
the same year.
Now, look at the teams for this along
the AI adoption curve.
Faros AI tracks this cohort in their
2026 benchmark.
Median PR review time is up by 441.5%
and if you see like if you calculate,
you'll figure out that the reviewed PRs
take 5.4 times longer than what they
used to. And then 31% more PR are now
merged with no review at all. So AI
produce AI is producing the code very
fast. AI is producing the pull request
very fast, but humans cannot responsibly
review them at that pace. This gap is
called as review debt. It actually
accrues quite a bit. It compounds and
right now nobody has a number for it.
But by the end of this talk, I will make
sure that you will have a certain
number.
Now, if you look at this particular
slide,
here is the story every team is telling
right now. PR per developer are up 16%.
That's the Faros AI acceleration
Whiplash benchmark and that from April
2026. There were like 22,000 developers,
4,000 teams. And the median PR size is
up 63%.
44 lines to 72 lines per pull request.
That is basically 16 months of long-term
data from DX 2026 study,
which includes 400 organizations.
Now, if you see the cycle time,
open to merge, that is modestly down and
it is coming from the same DX study. The
framing is really generous. PR
throughput grew actually about 8% and
the AI usage rose about 65%.
The gain that we see today is real, but
it is actually smaller than the hype
that that is present. Every one of these
numbers are real. None of them is a lie,
but everyone is a vanity metric. PR
count goes up when one PR splits into
seven PRs. Median PR size going up is
not a benefit, it's actually a bloating.
Cycle time going down when reviewers
stop pushing back. These things tell you
the speed of production. They do not
tell you the speed of trust.
Now, we will go into the next slide to
see more.
Now, if you go looking for the second
story, here is what you're going to
find. Reviewer fatigue. Engineers carry
far more review load than a year ago.
They're not happier about it.
Late-night merges. PRs are sitting
unreviewed for 3 days, 4 days, and then
they suddenly get a thumbs up at 11:00
p.m. before a Friday deadline.
Test theater.
Tests are getting added, but they're
actually asserting what the code did,
not what the code should do.
They lack in behavior, including bugs.
Architectural drift. Again, the same
problem that is solved in three
different ways in three different files.
Nobody is actually holding up the
architectural trade.
Finally, incident lag. When something
breaks, the bug lags week or months
after month uh after merge. Nobody
connects the dot back to the AI authored
change. These costs don't show up in any
dashboard until now.
We'll look into the next slide to know
more about it.
So now, let me give you the definition.
Review debt.
It's the accumulating gap between code
your agent has produced and the code
humans have actually reviewed, trusted,
and understood. It rhymes with technical
debt, but it is more like a financial
debt because it compounds. It actually
accrues interest, but this interest is
not money. This interest is paid in
human attention. It compounds because of
the three feedback loop. First, the
agent learns from your code base,
fine-tuning, rag grounding, in-context
suggestions.
Code that was not deeply reviewed
yesterday grounds tomorrow's PR.
This debt becomes generative in nature.
Second one, reviewers seed the
architectural call. When most of a PR
was generated, attention contracts to
syntax and obvious bugs. Big picture
decision moved from review time to
never.
Third one, velocity expectations reset.
Once leadership sees the new throughput,
you don't get to hire reviewers in
proportion. There is no slack left to
pay the debt back. Each loop on its own
is survivable. Together, you will have a
runway, but the next question is, how
are you going to measure it?
So,
how do we measure review debt? There are
five signal families that has like 10
deterministic checks. Remember, the
keyword here is deterministic. Every
check is computable from a pull request
and its repository.
No, we don't need any language model.
Why? Because LLM, when it acts as a
judge, it possibly can break two things.
Number one, the score becomes a moving
target. The same PR, basically the score
that you got for the same PR, will score
differently when your model will change.
Two,
the score stop being defensible in an
engineering review. You cannot put it on
a slide. You cannot put it in front of a
leadership. So, what do you want? You
want a number that is traceable to a
deterministic computation, different
size and coupling.
Second, test evidence gap. Third,
directory and ownership spread. Fourth,
AI authorship indicators. Fifth,
evidence and rational gaps. These are
the five families that will have 10
checks under them.
Let's walk
each of them.
The first one, the first signal that we
have is dev size and coupling.
This is the simplest one to calculate,
basically. It's also the most often
misread. What it measures is the net
lines changed, the files touched,
whether changes cluster in one module,
or is it sprawling across many. Why the
agent is struggling here? Agents are
biased toward fix at the call site. A
human engineer routes a fix to the root
cause. That keeps the difference very
small. But an agent will reach into many
files looking for the same symptom. The
review cost of a sprawling difference is
not proportional to the size. It is
actually much steeper.
So, the cross-file coupling explodes the
mental model and reviewer has to hold.
We'll look into the second signal, which
is test evidence gap.
So, what is test evidence gap? Test
evidence gap is nothing but test lines
added divided by the production lines
added per pull request. So, AI authored
PRs, they ship with a far lower test to
code ratio.
Sometimes there is no test file in
place. And if there is any, it's
minimal.
So, this gap is actually a consistent
gap. And the problem with this
particular thing is the number The
reason this number is basically brutal
is the agent generate test. They
generate a lot of test. But these test
basically assert what the code is doing.
It base It does not
generate the test cases what the code
should actually do. They lock in the
behavior including the bugs. The ratio
does not capture the quality gap. It
just measures whether the test showed up
at all.
So, the deeper signal
is the next step that is a layer down.
We'll see the next one, which is
directory and ownership spread.
So, what is directory and ownership
spread?
Count the distinct code owner teams
whose file appear in the difference.
Now, what does it mean?
Basically, a well-shaped PR concentrates
in one team directory. But a sprawling
one reaches across many team file. And
the review cost is enormous in this
scenario. No single human hold the whole
mental order model.
You need multiple approvals from
multiple engineers in multiple different
context. The coordination overhead
easily exceeds the time the agent save
producing the code. This is where you
start to feel the economics of review
debt. The agent gave you three hours of
typing. You spend those three hours by
multi-party reviewer attention.
And the next one we are going to see is
AI authorship indicators.
So, what is AI authorship indicator?
Before everyone gets defensive, this is
not for the blame. We are not flagging
that engineers use coding agents. We
wait the scores for a PR shape like
agent assisted authorship get extra
reviewer attention. So, that way you
know, right like, okay, this is the PR
that is directly coming from the agent.
And there are like the very common three
detection mode. I must I I think
everyone must have seen it by now. One
is the co-authored footer, which is
basically one of your strongest signal.
You see that co-authored by Copilot.
Second one is the branch name pattern.
Generally, you must have seen it says
codex, Copilot, cursor prefixes. Third
one is basic generated by assisted by,
which is nothing but your PR body. your
commit message phrases.
We did actually a real data check on
three public repos, which comprised of
524 PRs. I'm not going to name the
company, but for the sake uh we are just
calling it A, B, and C.
Now, if you see the highest signal was
the co-authored footer.
And the second one uh the lowest signal
was 0% on the repo C. Even though it was
done by coding agent, but they might
have blocked it uh saying any
co-authored or uh
like generated by etc. etc.
The next thing that we are going to see
is evidence and rational gaps.
So, evidence and rational gaps. I think
this is one of the most deterministic
that I personally feel. It's the one
that destroys review ability the
fastest. What it measures basically?
Does the PR explain the why or just the
what?
On the left, if you see, we have an high
gap. On the right, we have a low gap.
The title says "Fix leaky test" and all
the data that you're seeing here is
actually from some public repos.
Now, the PR body length is 18
characters, the commit message says
updates. Obviously, I will not be if you
give it to me, I won't be able to review
this. Okay, I cannot accept this.
But then on the right, if you see when
there is actually a low gap, the title
actually is telling you what the change
is all about. The body has a symptom,
the diagnosis, the change, and the link
to the benchmark. Now, a reviewer can do
the job.
So, in our regression fixtures and hands
code teams, this signal destroys
reviewability fastest. In the real open
source data, PR bodies follow
conventional commit format. So, it fires
most rarely there. But if you see the
regression fixtures are just the demos.
Okay, let's see how those five signals
combine.
You will only have one number that is
going from zero to 100. And the exact
weights are basically your defaults.
Now, if you're planning to adopt this, I
would like you to do this first. Run it
backwards over the last 200 PRs that
have been merged in your company.
Calibrate the weights against your
team's actual reviewer experience. The
score has to feel right against your
actual guts. We you you are going to
divide it into four bands.
If you are zero to 24, which means you
have very low review burden.
If you have 25 to 49,
you are normal, proceed with the
standard care. 52 74, you need evidence
from the author before senior review.
And if you're 75 and above, definitely
it's high split or request more context.
Same shape as technical debt categories,
but the unit is different. Now, we are
going to see what the scanner actually
did.
Now,
if you see this is the clean PR.
Unfortunately, I won't be able to give
you a live demo today, but I will walk
you through a CLI. I wanted you to show
three scored pull requests side by side,
the level where the framework become
useful as a repeatable review
conversation.
This is the first one.
If you see, this is what the scanner
says when a PR is all changed. Score out
zero out of 100. The burden is basically
nil. It's zero. We have a low review
burden. The estimated minutes is six. No
checks were fired.
And if you look the structure here,
that is why the list is empty. Reviewer
focus is empty. Author next action is
empty. The framework only generate
advice when it has something specific to
say. A healthy PR produces a tiny,
almost ceremonial report. That's exactly
what you want. And the takeaway is most
healthy PRs produce zero noise.
They get the work done without making
any noise. This is not a tool that
complains by default. Running it on
every PR cost you one comment that says
look good. That's it.
Let's see the high debt PR now.
Now, you see what you see actually on
the screen is from a public repo. This
is a real scenario from the scanner
regression suite.
If you see, the score is here 60 out of
100. It requires evidence.
It's on the audit and it says needs
evidence. 86 estimated minutes of review
effort. Look at the structured output.
It's actually not a score. A wire list
explaining what fired. A reviewer focus
list telling the reviewer what to do
next. An author next action list telling
the author how to bring the score down.
This is the part most PR quality tool
miss. The score alone is useful. The
structured advice is what actually moves
the team behavior.
Now, if you read the bullet point, it
says PR has soft indicators of AI
assisted authorship. This is information
only, not a definitive claim, and not a
penalty on its own.
This particular step sentence is in the
scanner output.
The AI indicator check contributes five
of the 60 points, which is nearly about
8%. The other 55 came from a different
size claim mismatch and missing test.
Those would be high burden signals on
any PR, agent authored or not authored.
This is not an anti-AI scorecard.
Basically, this is more of a review
burden scorecard. The agent did not
cause the score, but the shape of the PR
that is created by the agent did this.
Let's see the next one.
This is a PR, basically,
which is AI authored. It's very well
shaped, and the score is seven, seven,
which is low review burden.
Now, if you see the same agent, it has
done the same kind of work, but the test
were added. So, the CI is green. The
risky path is called out in the PR
description. That's why we got the score
as seven out of 100.
It's very low burden, took only 14
minutes. The AI indicator check still
fires, but it contributes 2.1. One, low
severity. Second, the framework
explicitly says, quoting the report
itself, "Information only, not a
definitive claim, and not a penalty on
its own."
So, when your team is going to ask,
"Will this tool penalize us for using
coding agents?" No, the answer is on
your screen, low review burden.
It's a very well shaped AI PR.
We are going to see the next one, which
is basically our three public repos over
524 PRs.
I wanted to show you a 90-day AI search
slope across three public repos and 524
pull request. The review burden climbs
even when the AI authorship doesn't.
If you see this particular scan, we
observe three things. One of them is the
volume is the actual variable. AI
authorship was flat and it was 5 to 20%
steady state, but the review burden was
not. If you see one repo accumulated 186
senior reviewer hours in 27 days and
another one took 43. The window length
is same, but the volume was not the
same. The burden was not the same. That
is what PR volume is. Second is
amplifier only holds up under real data,
which means AI indicators fired on 5 to
20% of PRs every week across all three
repos. None of those AI authored PRs
disproportionately landed in the high
burden band. The positioning contract
holds against real code bases. Third one
is complexity drives burden, not
authorship, which means across 524 PRs
four landed in needs evidence or high
bands, which means all four were
structural changes, which were large
migration, SDK rewrites, multi-team
refactors. The framework score
complexity fairly. AI driven volume
creates the condition under which these
accumulate.
So now, what 524 PR look like under the
lens? Where does the review debt
actually show up? In absolute terms, the
scanner saw 524 real pull request in
three public repos,
228 senior reviewer hours cumulative
across three public repos that were
scanned over 27 to 90-day windows.
Second one is nine PR per day sustained
merge rate the high velocity repo. So,
if you see, it's all about the volume
that is basically driving the burden.
Third one is 5,036. These are the
minutes that are basically spent on a
single PR, which is nothing but 84 hours
of review effort estimated for one
single pull request.
The score that we received there was 73,
which said it requires an evidence band.
Now, 5 to 25% of these PR every week
across every week fired at AI indicator
signal.
Again, remember this is volume,
which is causing the review debt, which
is changing the game altogether.
We'll move to the next slide. Measure
the problem. We have shown the cost.
Now, what do we do about it?
So, first thing is you should have one
logical change per PR. I'm not saying
like not small PR in the abstract. One
logical change, that is enough. Second,
test ship with the change. Even if the
agent wrote the code, even if the agent
wrote the test, the human author
confirms the test assert what the code
should do, not what the code is doing,
what the code is supposed to do. Okay?
Third, stay in one owner territory.
Cross-cutting work splitting into per
per team PR.
Remain in your own territory. One
approval, one context, one mental model.
Author writes the why. The agent should
not write the PR body. That's the moment
the human author commits to
understanding what they are actually
shipping.
Same review standard for the AI PRs as
human PRs. The AI indicator amplifier
only fires when other signals are weak.
Keep the other four strong. The
amplifier is invisible. So, make sure
there is no exception for AI. None of
these is actually requiring you to have
a new tool. These are the moves that you
already are aware of. You just need to
implement it.
Now,
how are you planning to adopt this?
If you see, we again have five steps.
Backfill, threshold, surface, aggregate,
and talk about it. Backfill. So, you run
the scorer over your last 200 merge PR.
Look at the one basically that has the
highest score.
Second, threshold. Set a basically
justify line. Default, let's say you
want to give it 50. So, any PR scored at
50 or above requires a comment from the
author. As simple as that. Surface it.
Post the score as a PR comment on every
PR. Don't block it. Just for the
visibility purpose, surface it so that
everybody should know what's happening
over there.
Aggregate weekly per team. Which means
the slope of each team deadline is the
leading indicator. That's what your
engineering manager should watch.
Talk about it. Bring the number to a
retrospective, every roadmap view.
In every meeting, you should discuss
about that number. Like, what was your
score when you did this particular PR.
That's it.
Why this number matter?
Because of this conversation? Absolutely
not.
Without a number, what you are just
conversing is why. But if you have a
number, it's actually structured. You
can tell like, okay, with AI coding
agents, we have a rollout which has
added X percentage of the throughput.
But you need to make sure you are also
adding the Y points of the review debt
that has been occurred over Z weeks.
Now, at your current slope, that's
roughly N senior N senior engineer hours
that you need to talk about.
That moves the discussion from feeling
to measurement. So, you should always
have a number.
If you see 2026, we are adopting things.
But, 2027 is the year when this
conversation will shift to the
governance model. And, it's actually
starting right now. Can you trust the
code that you're shipping? If yes,
we are good. If no, then who is
accountable when an AI authored change
causes an incident?
Where is the audit trail? So, reviewed
it is basically the bridge between these
two columns. It's the first number that
lets you have the right-hand side
conversation
without abandoning the left-hand side
gains.
We'll look into the final slide now.
Now,
three things I would like you to take
away. First one is, measure the gap.
Don't build the tooling yet. Take 20 PRs
from the last week, score them
using the five signals that we
discussed. You will basically get a
number so that you will understand,
okay, whether the framework is working
right or not.
Try to make the slope visible. The slope
of a reviewed it over time matters most
than the level. So, plot it weekly, and
then discuss it with your team maybe in
a meeting or in a sprint planning,
whatever the way you feel like. Have
this conversation. Bring the number to
your next review. Like, say that, okay,
we do have extra report, wide it, and
this is the slope. And, then you are
basically moving away from the wide
culture to the measurement culture.
One quick callout on anti-patterns to
avoid. First thing is, approve with
comment merges. The AI did the boring
part. No.
We'll catch it in QA. No. PRs smaller
now. No. Stop writing LGTM
on the PRs.
Make sure
whatever we have discussed, the habits
that we have discussed,
we are going to follow them. This is the
entire point of the talk. Thank you very
much for listening.